bonsoir nous sommes le 2 juin 2015
nouveau numéro du 7-8 politique je
recevrai tout à l'heure antoine dupin
directeur des relations territoriales
dans les yvelines pour le grand paris il
sera question des enjeux mais aussi de
cette concertation en cours autour de la
ligne 18 qui passera justement par notre
département
cette information tout d'abord pour
débuter cela concerne d'ailleurs ce
grand paris le nouveau préfet de région
jean françois carenco qui vient de
donner sa première interview depuis sa
nomination en avril dernier à nos
confrères du jdd il déclare vouloir
accélérer le dossier en misant d'abord
sur l'emploi mais aussi le logement
autre priorité pour lui faire aboutir la
candidature du pari de paris aux jo-2000
24 et interviews retrouvez en ligne sur
le site du journal du dimanche
premier invité de cette émission
françois dominiez bonsoir bonsoir maire
socialiste de guyancourt élus
d'opposition l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines vous êtes l'un de
ceux à dénoncer les réductions
budgétaires concernant la culture le
budget on va en parler justement avec
vous cette nouvelle majorité de centre
droit a décidé de faire des économies
les salles de spectacles vont être moins
doté son président demande d'ailleurs
aux communes de prendre leur
responsabilité en donnant pour ces
salles notamment plus de subventions
votre première réaction peut-être sur ce
budget et les choix qui ont été faits le
mois dernier michel laugier le président
s'est exprimé cette fois ci pour
l'opposition
je vous laisse dire quel est votre
regard on l'imaginé plus contrats dits
plus contrastée alors ma première
réaction en voyant le budget qui a été
présentée on y reviendra très
tardivement et sans associer du tout à
la préparation les élus que nous sommes
au bout de cette commune ma première
réaction c'est est de constater que le
grand oublié de ce budget c'est celle
habitants les habitants de saint quentin
en yvelines
sans oublier alors par rapport à l'accès
à la culture on va en parler précisément
mais finalement aussi quand on regarde
les baisses très importante pour les
associations ou encore pour le budget
social ou la politique de la ville il
faut faire des économies c'est ce qui
est dit parce que les dotations de
l'état ont diminué la culture pour
prendre le sujet de la culture ce n'est
pas une compétence obligatoire pour
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
on peut comprendre que ce soit l'une des
priorités pour réduire le budget
on regarde là où ce n'est pas
obligatoire alors il faut faire des
économies
bien évidemment chaque collectivité et
ma commune comme les autres est
confronté au fait que nous avons ce
besoin de faire des économies parce que
les ressources sont moins importantes
parce que la crise économique mais
finalement faire un budget c'est faire
des choix
hélas ce qu'on voit c'est que le
sacrifice et celui de de l'habitant les
services aux habitants
dans les autres collectivités avec des
baisses en fonctionnement on essaye
vraiment de maintenir le service aux
habitants et là dans le viseur on
retrouve encore une fois de la culture
les associations et même les
associations sociales mais vous le
feriez ou 16 économie il a écouté sur
d'abord géré marque fait remarquer tout
à l'heure que une des grandes
difficultés c'est qu'on n'a pas été
associée du tout
les mesures qui ont été prises ont été
pris sur la base d'audits il ya un audit
qui par exemple date de décembre 2014
il nous a été communiqué quatre jours
quatre jours avant le vote du budget
alors que dans les conseils des maires
précédents dont les bureaux précédent
dans les réunions publiques précédentes
nous avions réclamé d'avoir les moyens
de regarder et pourquoi parce que dans
nos communes je vous donne un exemple à
guyancourt on a des ressources en moins
comme beaucoup de communes
eh bien nous avons fait des choix mais
en veillant à ce que encore une fois et
sans augmenter les impôts et en veillant
à ce que ça ne soit pas le service à
l'habitant donc c'est bien d'habitants
qui est sacrifiée choix porté sur quoi
elle a alors un exemple pour les
équipements culturels à guyancourt on
avait maintenu deux les moyens pour les
équipements culturels là qu'est ce qui
se passe on nous dit c'est aux communes
2 à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est notre histoire notre histoire
commune c'est l'identité même de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les
équipements intercommunaux lui aussi les
équipements communaux étaient aidés par
les communautés d'agglomération et
brutalement en cours d'année au mois
d'avril une coupe énorme 33% en moins de
subventions pour les équipements
communaux
au total ça fait 4 144 mille euros en
moins brutalement et avec l' annonce
puisque c'est marqué dans l'audit qu'on
a découvert du fait que ça serai à 100%
donc là on dit c'est c'est très brutal
d'une part ça a été fait sans discussion
et encore une fois d'autres façons plus
haut possible
la semaine dernière il y avait un grand
cocktail pour le pour un film sur le bmx
je ne sais pas combien ça a coûté de
même je ne sais pas très bien en place
et l'inauguration de la piste par
exemple je ne sais pas très bien quand
on côté les audits
mais prenons l'exemple des audits
l'audit sur le périmètre de l'interco
alors que les les périmètres était déjà
débattu nous combien ça coûte et
pourquoi ça a été fait est ce que
c'était vraiment les choix à faire
donc sur la forme je trouve que c'est
pas respectueux de ne pas avoir associé
4d commune iv de cette commune et sur le
fond un budget c'est toujours toujours
une question de choix d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour dire que là c'était le
budget primitif servir le budget pour
l'exercice 2015 et vous le savez dans un
exercice budgétaire ya ce qu'on appelle
dit le budget supplémentaire
ouiiiii les rectificatifs bien justement
rectifions vous pensez pouvoir encore
obtenir des désinfections on va venir
sur la culture juste pour la forme
pour michel laugier vous avez pratiqué
c'est en fait la politique de la chaise
vide vous n'êtes pas venu sur les
différentes réunions
je m'inscris en faux la seule réunion et
on l'a fait pour dire attention là ça
devient de la mascarade
c'est la dernière réunion du débat
d'orientation budgétaire mais je voulais
dit tout à l'heure avec précision c'est
après de nombreuses réunions ou n'a pas
écouté le fait qu'on voulait avoir le
contenu des audits
quand on dit que les audits ont été
donnés quatre jours avant le vote alors
que les documents étaient datées du mois
de décembre c'est à dire qu'ils ont été
gardés secret pendant des mois il ya
quelque chose d'anormal et on a marqué
le coup alors on dit on aurait pu
participer comment voulez-vous
participer quand réunion après réunion
conseil de mer après conseil des maires
ont demandé documents et qu'on ne les a
pas le choisir les contenus d'audit le
choix des suppressions de 33 % de
subventions pour les équipements
communaux culturel on les a découverts
comme je voulais dit on a découvert
aussi que l'audit comprenait la
suppression d' équipements
intercommunaux également sans discussion
c'est la maison de la poésie
mais la maison de l'environnement et il
ya même des noms fois parce qu'on n'a
pas parlé du tout mais on apprend par
une convocation à une réunion que par
exemple la prochaine réunion concernant
l'office du tourisme
l'ordre du jour c'est dissolution
je pose la question est-ce que d'un
point de vue gouvernance est-ce que d'un
point de vue fonctionnement démocratique
on est en tort non ce qu'ils sont en
tort c'est ce qui refuse d'associer et
une intercommunalité
ça doit être une coopérative début on
doit travailler ensemble et unir nos
forces pour un territoire plus large que
sa plus simple commune celui de
l'intercommunalité
d'ailleurs au niveau des équipements
culturels moi ce que je remarque c'est
comme pour les associations les faits va
être terrible on ne se rend pas compte
encore aujourd'hui
mais quand on regarde les conséquences
directes cela veut dire que des
équipements ne vont plus pouvoir
fonctionner je peux donner juste deux
chiffres les gens parce qu'on les a pas
donné un seul de la batterie à
guyancourt concerne directement votre
commune 66600 67 euros de moins pour la
salle de bel ébat cinquante mille cinq
cents 464 euros de moins sur des budgets
conséquents alors en gros ça veut dire
115000 pour l'année pleine
et ça veut dire que puisqu'on nous
annonce que ses 33 % ça pourrait devenir
100 % c'est le risque que de demain ça
soit le 3 x 3 x cela c'est à dire
comment vous compensez et bien voilà
comment s comment est ce qu'on avait
déjà pensé alors nous irons sur lui de
se débrouiller mais vous avez remarqué
qu'il ya des équipements comme le prisme
qui qu'il a et heil en cours et qu'il
sera intercommunale on n'est pourtant
pas dans la compétence mais là on n'y
touche pas nationale qui continue à voir
la célébration de la scène nationale la
scène nationale et les engagements
effectivement des engagements de et
c'est bien normal puisque c'est une
scène nationale de différentes
collectivités mais juste une remarque
oui la ferme de bel ébat elle a le même
rayonnement le même nombre de
spectateurs
l'éclectisme de la programmation mais
elle a aussi ce qu'on appelle l'action
culturelle auprès des publics je pense
par exemple à la sensibilisation qui est
faite auprès des scolaires ou auprès des
publics les plus éloignés de la culture
et bien c'est tout ce travail là qui
étaient jusqu'à présent organisé en
bonne intelligence entre le niveau
agglomérations et le niveau communes qui
pourraient s'effondrer pourtant vous
regarderez dans l'audit puisque
maintenant on alloue dit la ferme de bel
ébat dans son rayonnement
les qui vaut au prisme mais juste pour
être précis la ferme du manet à montigny
la ferme du mousseau et encourt aussi
voient leur dotation diminué bien sûr
mais ce que je suis en train de dire
c'est que c'est bien non
bleu des structures de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et des
associations de saint quentin en
yvelines qu'il faut défendre
je fais simplement la remarque quand on
dit mais on va garder le prisme
ça veut dire que toutes les autres et
vous venez d'en citer d'autres et on
aurait pu dire le scarabée l'estaminet
la mûrissent le crédit à celle vont
connaître de gros déboires
c'est pas bon pour les habitants je
reviens à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure ce budget il se caractérise par
le fait qu'on a oublié les habitants un
territoire et ça s'est développé comme
ça à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est c'est pour les habitants c'est
avec les habitants d'ailleurs vous savez
ce qui fait l'attractivité y compris
d'une entreprise qui veut venir
s'installer c'est la qualité de son
cadre de vie mais c'est aussi ce qu'on
est capable d'offrir à ses habitants et
les collaborateurs d'entreprises sont
aussi des futurs habitants
j'en profite pour dire d'ailleurs que
malgré la crise économique
saint quentin en yvelines et vous savez
que j'ai téléchargé du développement
économique et donc je peux dire que
l'accueil saint quentin en yvelines
était est toujours le deuxième pôle
économique de l'île de france nous ne
faisons pas comme si aujourd'hui tout
devait s'arrêter
quant au désendettement avec un contexte
budgétaire bien sûr et plus serré comme
pour les villes quant au désendettement
le désendettement était déjà commencé il
s'agit de le poursuivre nous ce qu'on
propose c'est on est on est disponible
pour le travail pour la réflexion et je
le disais tout à l'heure pour les choix
à faire
ce qui est terrible c'est de ne pas
pouvoir participer à des choix et ce qui
est terrible c'est de constater que ces
choix ils remettent en cause la place de
l'habitant c'est l'habitant qui oblige
concernant la culture la maison de la
poésie qui éventuellement pourraient
disparaître mais qui serait remplacé par
une mission poésie donc la majorité
actuelle dit ne pas oublier la culture
mais de repenser la culture votre
opinion en commençant la maison à paris
situés sur votre colonne on commencera
par supprimer brutalement et sans
concertation préalable aucune en
commençant par supprimer la structure
c'est à dire le lieu c'est à dire la
petite maison de la poésie qui a
pourtant un grand rayonnement et
d'ailleurs vous avez vu que s'il ya plus
de près de 3000 lettres de
pétitionnaires pour demander son
maintien
ça veut dire que vous savez c'est pas
dans les quelques mètres carrés de la
maison de la poésie que tout se fait ça
veut dire que là il ya une structure il
ya un lieu il ya une équipe et il ya un
rayonnement encore une fois pour tous
les publics
pas pour quelques-uns pour tous les
publics y compris pour les scolaires
regardez sur les pétitionnaires vous
avez beaucoup de professeurs beaucoup
d'associations
beaucoup d'acteurs du territoire qu'ils
disent mais c'est un outil formidable et
pourquoi tout d'un coup sans prendre
moi je crois que j'ai la réponse j'ai le
sentiment malheureusement que la
nouvelle gouvernance de la communauté
d'agglomération s'attaque à un symbole
et quand on s'attaque aux symboles de la
culture
si on y réfléchit bien on en revient aux
habitants la culture qu'est ce que c'est
c'est pas seulement les veilles des
esprits c'est pas simplement le fait
d'être sensibilité à des z'arts d'être
sensibilisés par don à des z'arts c'est
aussi pour moi la culture c'est aussi le
vivre ensemble c'est aussi la cohésion
sociale c'est aussi le lien avec les
compagnies avec les artistes
avec les nombreuses associations à
travers la pétition qui a été mis en
place à travers la mobilisation aussi
parce qu'à une manifestation la semaine
dernière juste avant la tenue du conseil
communautaire vous avez pu le suivre sur
notre antenne je propose d'écouter un
extrait c'est une intervention de michel
logist et sur notre plateau le mois
dernier il réagissait justement à ces
différentes questions d'orientation
budgétaire
on remet pas du tout en question la
culture en plus ce titre personnel et en
tant que maire de montigny montini la
ville qui concentre le plus de budget à
la culture des sept communes de 2,51
sauf que moi la coupe d'été de l'agglo
ne m'a pas beaucoup aidé mais je le fais
parce que c'est je trouve que c'est une
priorité
donc je pense que chaque maire aussi
doit s'assumer puisque finalement l'aide
au spectacle vivant qui est gérée par
les collectivités qui est gérée par les
villes
et bien c'est à chaque commune de
pouvoir aussi assumer il ya des
priorités communes n'ont pas les mêmes
marges dans les budgets aussi pour
pouvoir financer cette culture allez
devoir de solidarité en ramadan mais la
solidarité elle s'exerçait ailleurs
puisque je donne de 38 millions d'ha
même aux communes en plus
après bien sûr tout oeil tout elle tous
les travaux je pouvais dire aussi que
aujourd'hui dans la préparation de notre
budget toutes les demandes prioritaires
qui avait été demandé par chéque eu des
des communes ont été satisfaites
eh bien ça compte en humaine quand on
écoute michel de levier tu es toujours
cette dotation qui est faite aux
communes pour les dépenses prioritaires
la culture globalement n'est pas remise
en cause c'est son discours mais j'ai
écouté avec attention il ya quelque
chose qui est plus frais mais
complètement c'est d'opposer les uns et
aux autres
nous sommes sur un même territoire
l'intercommunalité se sont
des décennies où on a travaillé ensemble
pour construire l'identité de saint
quentin en yvelines
et puis à une phrase qui m'a
particulièrement choqué je suis désolé
de le dire c'est quand monsieur logis
dit je donne vous rappeler ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure qui s'exprimeraient
la majorité et bien justement le jeu
donne c'est le mot qui signifie un
moment donné à quel point vous pouvez
ressentir que nous on s'est sentis
exclus
or nous sommes également des
représentants des habitants
on représente chacun des habitants et
moi ce que je voudrais dire c'est que à
tout moment dans ma lecture du budget
c'est l'attention portée aux habitants
qui m'importe
et quand j'entends dire qu'on oppose
telle ou telle commune
et dire que certains n'auraient pas fait
des efforts et c'est quand on regarde
bien la politique culturelle comme la
politique en direction des associations
à saint quentin en yvelines
c'était au fond l'idée qu'ils pouvaient
avoir le le niveau intercommunal il
niveau communal que les deux étaient
complémentaires et qu'on travaillait
pour le ciment du territoire et le
ciment du territoire je voudrais le dire
quand même c'est la cohésion sociale
crds merci à la cohésion sociale
merci françois de ligne et merveilleux
d'opposition socialiste à la casse qui
en colère comme d'autres après à la
réduction entre autres des dépenses de
la culture à saint quentin en yvelines
merci à vous lui aussi il n'est pas
content des réductions budgétaires ils
siègent avec vous d'ailleurs à saint
quentin en yvelines en tant qu'élu
attrape c'est benoît hamon le député des
yvelines ancien ministre il sera
l'invité du café politique à découvrir
dès ce mardi soir sur notre antenne je
vous propose d'en écouter un extrait il
est question du congrès de poitiers qui
va s'ouvrir dans quelques jours le
congrès des socialistes vous en attendez
quoi concrètement de ce rendez-vous vous
qui jusqu'à présent vous êtes montré
plutôt critique sur ce qui a été fait
par le gouvernement depuis deux ou trois
ans
bon j'ai été critiques sur certains
aspects pas surtout que j'étais ministre
j'en avais quitté le point sur lequel je
reste réservé ce sont les politiques
économiques et sociales en clair on a on
le voit ici sur ce territoire derrière
des français qui vend des problèmes de
pouvoir d'achat des problèmes de la vie
quotidienne qui reste important
d'emplois souffrance au travail et c est
ce qu on attend de la gauche
dire qu'on soit de droite ou gauche
quand la gauche arrive au pouvoir c'est
qu'il y ait davantage de justice sociale
je pense que sur cet aspect là il faut
qu'on exploite les deux ans qui viennent
totalement sur ce terrain là moi
j'attends des modifications voilà pour
le café politique à découvrir ce mardi
donc sur notre antenne je reçois à
présent pour le 7-8 politique antoine
dupin bonsoir 7 directeur territorial de
la société du grand paris en charge plus
particulièrement de ce département des
yvelines la semaine dernière se
déroulait une réunion à guyancourt
réunion de concertation autour de la
ligne 18 qui doit relier dans plusieurs
années l'aéroport d'orly à versailles
chantiers en passant par saint quentin
en yvelines avant d'évoquer ce dossier
j'aimerais tout de même votre réaction à
cette décision hier lundi 1er juin des
sénateurs de repousser d'un an la
création de la métropole du grand paris
le pour eux les travaux préparatoires la
mise en place ne seront pas terminés est
ce que tout ça peut avoir une incidence
sur les différents projets qui sont
menés sur le terrain
vous savez le métro de toute façon de
bien sûr inséré dans un paysage
institutionnel qui est aujourd'hui ce
qu'il est la métropole est quelque chose
qui va se mettre en place
bien entendu la la société du grand
paris et le métro desservira également
le nouveau paysage institutionnel et
s'insérera dans cette dans ce nouvel
environnement tout état de cause si dans
tout état de cause nous sommes dans des
calendriers parallèle jusqu'aujourd'hui
nous travaillons avec sous l'égide d'un
conseil de surveillance qui rassemble à
la fois des élus des territoires
notamment les présidents de conseils
départementaux
le président de la région ile de france
la maire de paris et puis également bien
sûr les administrateurs de l'état
puisque je rappelle que la société du
grand paris est une société d'état il ya
malgré certaines réticences au jour
d'une unanimité autour de ce projet du
grand paris il ya des enjeux qui sont
très importants quelles sont ces
différents enjeux justement c'est de
rendre dynamique sur le plan économique
de permettre une concurrence globale
avec les autres territoires français et
les autres territoires en france et puis
à travers l'europe
c'est évident que
aujourd'hui la région parisienne en
termes économiques a explosé dans les
frontières anciennes issues du 19e et du
20e siècle
aujourd'hui la croissance des
déplacements se fait essentiellement de
banlieue à banlieue
alors que les infrastructures de
transport ont été créés pour converger
vers le centre de paris notamment je
pense à la majorité des rer qui se
croisent quelque part une fois à
châtelet et donc pour aller de banlieue
à banlieue
il faut souvent passer par le centre de
paris le grand paris a une vocation de
métro automatique en rocade pour
permettre de de créer des
correspondances qui permettront aux
banlieusards d'aller de d'une banlieue à
une autre en fonction de leurs objectifs
de transport de loisirs et tous les
objectifs qui aujourd'hui font ceux de
la vie quotidienne ce grand paris c'est
une réalité concrète aujourd'hui parce
que pour les habitants ça reste malgré
tout un peu abstrait on parle beaucoup
mais c'est un projet effectivement qui
se développe comme tous les projets
d'infrastructure sur plusieurs années
mais très concrètement aujourd'hui sur
le premier tronçon qui va relier le pont
de sèvres à boulogne billancourt
jusqu à champs-sur-marne bien les
travaux ont démarré les travaux ont
démarré dans plusieurs les travaux
préparatoires ce qu'on appelle la
dérivation des réseaux ont démarré
effectivement et la déclaration
d'utilité publique sur ce premier
tronçon a également été obtenus dans les
délais qui avaient été fixés par la
société du grand paris
on parle justement de cette ligne 18
concertation en cours 35 km de nouvelles
infrastructures pour relier l'aéroport
d'orly à versailles chantiers en passant
par les pour le paris saclay et saint
quentin en iv c'est en concertation sont
peu repris 6 un petit peu le calendrier
sur les différentes réunions et les
différents enjeux autour de tout ça
alors la concertation elle s'est
déroulée
il s'agissait par rapport à un projet
qui a été très largement débattu avec
les représentants des habitants les élus
dans de nombreux comités techniques
comité de pilotage il s'agissait de
retourner devant le grand public devant
les habitants du territoire pour leur
montrer qu'elle est elle le projet
proposé par la société du grand paris et
recueillir leurs observations leurs
objections sur ce sur ce grand projet
donc cette concertation elle et elle est
pilotée par la société du grand paris
qui a demandé qu un garant de la
concertation qui est neutre et qui
regarde si le débat est transparent si
l'on fournit assez d'informations madame
jarry donc qui est la garante de cette
concertation suis chacune des réunions
qui a lieu il y a eu six réunions
publiques
plus maintenant un certain nombre de
réunions complémentaires vers les
publics spécialisés les entreprises les
centres de recherche qui sont nombreux
dans ce territoire et donc toutes ces
réunions
la dernière aura lieu d'ailleurs
à magny les hameaux elle aura lieu le 11
juin prochain et donc nous terminerons
ce cycle et après la garante va rédiger
un rapport
et bien entendu ceux qui n'ont pas pu
aller aux réunions publiques peuvent
s'adresser sur notre site internet de la
société du grand paris pour déposer
leurs questions il y sera répondu sous
l'oeil vigilant de madame jarry la
garante
donc il peut y avoir des modifications
sur ce qui est proposé aujourd'hui à
l'issue de ces concertations des
ajustements alors la ligne vers la ligne
telle qu'elle est décrite aujourd'hui
elle est largement elle est largement
figée dans son dans son contexte dans
son tracé et dans ses gares et les figer
aussi parce que il faut savoir que la
feuille de route du grand paris c'est un
schéma d'ensemble qui a été publiée en
2011 en conseil d'état
et ce décret en conseil d'état fixe les
gars fixe le remplacement et fixent
également le tracé de façon générale
alors bien entendu après à la marge on a
capacité à déplacer de quelques séries
serait autour de la concertation c'est
tout l'aménagement qu'est autour les
liaisons avec par exemple les pôles
économiques et relier les gares à
certains endroits de saint quentin en
yvelines par exemple voilà par exemple à
saint quentin en yvelines la gare sera
situé sur un territoire en développement
puisque c'étaient des territoires qui
aujourd'hui sont
abandonnée c'est une friche industrielle
devant le technocentre de renault est
donc ce territoire de 22 hectares va à
la fois permettre un développement
urbain va permettre du logement parce
que l'une des vocations aussi 2 du métro
du grand paris c'est de permettre
d'ouvrir de nouveaux territoires
logement vous connaissez les difficultés
de logement dans cette région est donc
le grand paris et les gars vont
permettre de développer des centres de
logements vont permettre aussi de décès
de desservir le lait les entreprises
alentour et dieu sait qu'elles sont
nombreuses à saint quentin
je pense notamment au technocentre qui
sera en phase avec ses attend avec
impatience effectivement se salir iard
avec tous les salariés qui sont présents
l'investissement global ces 22 milliards
d'euros c'est ces 26 milliards de
milliards d'euros le budget avec l'eau
le budget willow budget est largement
clos pour pour pour réaliser ce schéma
d'ensemble qui est dont j'ai parlé tout
à l'heure qui prévoit de façon
exhaustive les gares telles qu'elles
sont telles qu'elles sont décrites
aujourd'hui tels qu'on les présente au
grand public vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure vous rencontrez grand public ça
c'est dans le cadre des concertations il
ya aussi des réunions secondaire avec
les entreprises par exemple quel est
votre rôle au milieu de tout ça c'est
d'expliquer combien c'est nécessaire
peut-être de demander aux entreprises
aussi une participation d'
investissement alors aujourd'hui le
métro du grand paris est financée
globalement et totalement par une
fiscalité fléché c'est à dire des impôts
qui sont perçus en taxes additionnelles
notamment sur la taxe additionnelle aux
taxes d'habitation taxes foncières
payées par les ménages de la région ile
de france
donc quelque part il est considéré comme
et les entreprises participent aussi au
travers d'une taxe sur les bureaux qui a
été qu'ils donnent aussi la poste la
capacité à la société du grand paris de
façon autonome bien sûr sous le contrôle
de l'état
cet argent c'est de l'argent public mais
de façon autonome de permettre d'asseoir
les futurs emprunts qui seront
nécessaires pour atteindre à tout le
monde
voilà c'est bien les parties puis avec
les entreprises l'argent liens utiles le
grand paris des états presse est
financée et la ligne 18 également est
financé pour sa réalisation telle
qu'elle est prévue vous l'avez dit
prochaine réunion ce sera le 11 juin à
manuel et hameaux pour cette ligne 18
merci entonnent les bains est d'être
passé sur plateau directeur territorial
de la société du groupe à je vous
remercie
une dernière information politique elle
concerne l encours et le maire jean
michel fourgous attaqué en justice par
le directeur de cabinet de guy malandain
le maire socialiste de trappes rogatien
bouchereau vient de déposer plainte pour
diffamation et injure non publique pour
lui il faut montrer que tout n'est pas
permis dans le débat public le maire
d'elancourt estime être victime du str
d'une stratégie de déstabilisation
c'est la fin de cette édition du 7 8
politique rendez vous le 30 juin pour le
dernier numéro de cette saison